okay
welcome back
happy new year
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to river with griffin y'all
2022 edition happy new year so excited
we're back at it again
so you know let's just get that this
yeah back at it again
we're from griffin 2022
happy new year um make sure you check me
out daily on
twitch i am at eric griffin gaming
always on twitch
uh but before we get started uh shout
out to
our sponsor door
dash doordash connects you with
everything you want whenever you and
however you want it get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on your first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code griffin
doordash
all right y'all
here we are
excuse me we're griffin i am c word free
uh you know i took a test everything's
good you know christmas and new year's
was like a little dodgy for me but it is
what it is i'm good i do have like a
lingering cough but that to me is i
always have like issues during
winter time because of my sinuses i get
that sinus drip and that causes a cough
so but it's just tough because right now
if you cough or you have any kind of
bodily function that
you know is like cold related you know
how people are they're like oh no he got
it so but i'm good
um
welcome back you know y'all welcome back
uh thanks for being here we're from with
griffin i had to do it live because you
know again i'm just
sometimes it's easier for me to just do
it live and i trust myself
excuse me i'm drinking something for all
you people and thanks for everybody
being here on youtube that are watching
me on live on youtube and for everybody
listening to me later
on all the podcast platforms thank you
for your support too i appreciate that
um i'm gonna start doing some things a
little not different but like more of
the things that i think i like doing and
people like you know i'm gonna do more
movie and show reviews
more recaps of movies
i usually do the recap of movies when
it's like a shitty movie that's my
favorite thing to do just recap like a
guilty pleasure type movie from
beginning to end
so we'll check that out also uh i think
i'm gonna come in here and start reading
some of the uh some of the comments from
previous episodes like to go into like
discussion about that you know what i
mean because i do appreciate uh when you
guys interact so i gotta let you guys
know
when you know what what you're saying
when you interact so i'll just you know
come in here and look at these um
um you know
look at look at some of the comments and
so so people could get some shout outs
for that too so you know that's how we
gonna do it here
in
2022 thought you knew i'm live so if
you're in the la area tonight i'm at the
improv with eric and friends at the lab
it's a little small room holds like 50
people we usually get a good little
crowd and i got some good comics on the
show tonight so if you want to or you
know or if you you know if you listen to
this later you missed it but every month
i do that at the improv in hollywood on
every first monday of the month so you
might want to uh check that out
what's up again to the chat thanks for
being here so you know
um
[Music]
let me see so if i'm looking at last
week's episode i i reviewed the matrix
so
i got a lot of people that are
you know they sent me messages about the
matrix movie some people had some good
things to say about my review some
people had bad things to say about my
review but you know it is what it is
i'm trying to find one
let me just find one that was like
you know like somebody said that i
should have like looked at the movie
again and i missed some major plot
points and my whole point about that is
like yo
if you have to like
if you have to um
look at this damn thing
if you have to look at that movie like
if you have to watch a movie more than
once
you have to watch a movie more than once
to like figure out
some some plot points to make the movie
make sense and it didn't grab you
initially then that's not a good movie
you know like i don't care how many
you know i don't care how many times you
look at that
there's nothing that was gonna make the
new matrix good to me all right the new
matrix was just
garbanzo beans so
oh yeah this was from shout out to
rolando
in the ch in the comments rolando
segovia i'm not sure how to say the name
but he said eric i love you but you need
to watch the matrix more than once you
missed a lot and he has a lot in like
capital letters of plot and characters
uh love you keep up the great work yeah
i i didn't miss anything okay
you know they just weren't speaking loud
enough or it wasn't important enough uh
you know it was pretty pretty garbanzo
beans uh that movie man
so
you're gonna have to like uh
i i i completely disagree with
anybody that liked the matrix movie
so new year's was fun it was just me
rachel and i just here we didn't do
anything we didn't go out cause she
actually got it you know what i mean so
you all know i'm free of it but rachel
got it
but she was her symptoms were so light
that she you know she's already feeling
great
and you know and then now she gets off
work because her work is still like they
still on the 10-day thing
so you know but you know we're looking
good right now and we got a bunch of
tests in case we need them so you know i
got that but yeah so we just spent a
little we just spent time here
counted down you know we got dressed up
and rachel took pictures
she always wants to take like we didn't
even take pictures at midnight she's we
set it up ahead of time and started she
wants to like take a bunch of pictures
like that
and then we felt good and then new
year's day we went and got some sushi
which was really delicious
uh this sushi place out here in marina
del rey it's one of those ones where you
have to like take your shoes off and you
sit in the ground you know it's like one
of those like fancy type sushi it was
really good so shout out to that sushi
place
i forgot the name of the place it's like
some sushi name you know what i mean
if you wonder what i'm drinking i'm
drinking lollipop
they're not a sponsor but i wish they
would sponsor me and send me some free
stuff but lollipop's actually pretty
dope it's only 35 calories soda and it's
got a lot of good stuff in it for you so
it's like the only it's like a sparkling
tonic they call it
uh some of the flavors though it's like
you think it's this flavor but it's not
really this flavor even though it don't
but you can taste like they're trying to
make it that flavor so shout out to uh
lollipop if you want to come come
sponsor with griffin i would love that
uh rick glassman's out here in the uh
the chats uh shout out to rick glassman
who makes you check out take your shoes
off i'm probably gonna go on his podcast
again
um so shout out to rick i actually
should have got you on live right now
rick
[Laughter]
you know we actually could call we i i
should oh man i should have set it up
where i could have got him in
uh you know a lot you know live on the
thing i'll do it another time since but
shout out to rick glassman and make sure
you check out take your shoes off
podcast but anyways um here we are guys
uh riffle with griffin once again this
year so i'm gonna go right into uh some
of the reviews that i wanted to talk
about this year
um i'm gonna do more of this uh like i'm
rebranding the podcast you know but i
like i like talking about this so let's
talk about book of boba fett the star
wars story
star wars book of boba fett i love that
they're doing this
i've talked about this before but i
really enjoy when they take like a
universe that we know and love we know a
lot about the universe and then they go
let's make a bunch of shows and movies
in this same universe i think that's
great star wars has been a part of my
life since i was like you know since 77
i was like five or six years old however
old i was that's how long i've been you
know thinking about star wars and it's
like it's great you know we've had so
many movies so many like cartoons
excuse me so much stuff that goes in
with uh star wars and uh you know
they made this show now
mandalorian
by the way i'm gonna be talking about
this show throughout for the next like
10 episodes whatever so i'll have a
little tidbit about if something good
happens in the show
you know i'll talk about it try not to
spoil it but it is what it is you have
your if you're into it go watch it if
you haven't watched it i don't care i
might spoil it that's just on you
you know what i mean so this is like a
spoiler alert podcast at all times when
we're talking about shows and movies it
is what it is
but all right so
you had the mandalorian which was a
really great show i really enjoyed the
mandalorian i loved just
the baby yoda and everything about it
the style of it i love the feel the look
i love the story i love the acting it
was the mandalorian was just so
understated and
you know
uh so much emotion was conveyed without
even seeing people's face it's a
testament to the creators of that show
it was like it was it was really good
okay so shout out to them for that wait
let me make sure i got
oh wait i had it on here
um so then you got this book of boba
fett now the star so book of boba fett
though here's my
here's my uh um issues with book of boba
fett so far like i don't know
where this is in the timeline like i
don't know if they if they if they've if
they've expressed it
uh
you know
i don't know if they've expressed it i
don't know if they've like said
like this is
this is uh where this is
you know in the in the in the timeline
of star wars or in in terms of like in
the timeline for um
mandalorian
i i have no idea but it stars this guy
tamora morrison and he's been in the
star wars universe now for a while i
actually thought he was the original
boba fett but he's not he's not the
original boba fett but he took over all
the boba fett duties
uh you know he was the guy that was like
the clone that boba fett was based off
of in those in those terrible star wars
ones the the supposed like prequel ones
that they they came out with
um
you know and so then you know he's now
they they took him they made him you
know he's boba fett so the first one the
first episode
you
they're doing a lot of like time jumping
a lot of flashback time jumping okay now
my problem is this guy playing boba fett
is he's like 60 and he looks 60 and it's
fine i have no problem with that but
there's sort of time jumping back where
he is like they're boba fett from return
of the jedi
so like they do this thing where like
you're you're finding out what happened
to boba fett because
at last we saw boba fett the last time
we really saw boba fett was return of
the jedi which would be book six of the
star wars and boba fett was attacking
han solo in them and jabba the hutt's um
you know uh what do you call it his
yacht his desert yacht
and you know han solo and and you know
luke skywalker is gonna rescue han solo
and princess leia and then there's a big
fight and boba fett falls into that like
monster in the in the thing and
apparently he's gonna be digested for
you know a thousand years or whatever
however they they said it was going to
work
right
so in the book of boba fett you kind of
see
boba fett wakes up in the stomach of
this
monster with like storm troopers and
you know everybody that was gonna like
get messed up he got messed up in that
fight and he is escaping okay so he
escapes you know what i mean he gets out
of there
now my problem is i don't know when this
was
like so
did this monster
keep boba fett alive
for
30 years
and he was down in this thing and now
he's finally come to his senses and he
escaped because when he went he gets
those little sand creatures who were
like always in like the big like big
tank thing in the star wars series and
they're like these little creatures that
steal everything you know they come and
they he's like laying in this desert and
they steal all his stuff they steal his
like boba fett armor and all that all
his mandalorian armor or whatever they
they stole from him
his you know and then um
he's laying in the sun but he's laying
in the sun as like this guy like the 60
year old man
you know and i'm like so this is a young
boba fett or we don't even know how old
boba fett was you know in terms of star
wars but in the timeline i don't know
where anything is like where is this you
know what i mean like when is this the
sarlacc pit thank you uh star wars nerds
in the chat and everybody that's
listening right now screaming at the
radio or or they're whatever they're
listening this or this on you know
they're like it's the story like pit
idiot you know so there we go so
i don't know and then the jawas thank
you thank you see that's why i like
doing it live because the star wars
nerds are on point giving me all the
facts so i don't know where this is in
the timeline is what i'm saying so like
how long was he in that pit before he
escaped
so then apparently he escapes but then
the jawas take all his stuff and then
those other ones what are the other ones
called like i forget what the other ones
are called but they like kidnap him and
they take him to their village and now
they you know they're you know they got
him
like tied up you know and he's
flashbacking on this he's flashing back
on this so you can find out this is what
happened to boba fett then there's a
whole thing that happens and i won't
spoil that like you find out like you
know how he where
where whatever all the stuff that was
happening to him
now it's like i said it's hard to figure
out where
it is in the timeline like like
are these events of the book of boba
fett before the mandalorian or after the
mandalorian
to me it feels like this is before the
mandalorian okay but i don't know i'll
have to figure it out as the season goes
on but as of looking at episode one and
that's what this up this podcast is
about episode one i have no idea i don't
know where this is like the flashbacks
you know it's hard to tell so now boba
fett is in tatooine right that's where
uh jabba jabba's palace are the same
people thank you the tuscan raiders
thank you guys oh i love the chat chat
right now is on point thank you nerds
um
you know so he's with them and then okay
so that's a time jump all right so now
cut you like your current times he's now
taking over
for jabba the hutt so jabba's dead but
we don't know how long job has been dead
you know what i'm saying like uh so now
he's now the new lord of whatever he's
this like you know and so now you can
see that this is about this the criminal
underworld because jabba was like this
mobster that was running stuff so now
you know he's taking over so people are
coming and give him their they're like
they're coming to give him gifts like
hey you know you're the new leader but
this is what i this is one of the things
i don't like as of right now
boba fett is
like he's one of the dark characters of
the stories of all you know like he's a
badass like boba fett is supposed to be
like all business i am a
bounty hunter that darth vader himself
kept kept him close like darth vader was
like we gotta keep boba fett around
because that's how badass he is
you know what i'm saying
and then
all of a sudden now they're trying to
make him a hero and when they try to
make somebody a hero who's a bad guy
you kind of like okay so i have this
empathy for this guy and i'm like okay
so now boba fett's supposed to be this
good figure he ain't man he a bounty
hunter that kills people you know what
i'm saying he kills people for money and
he you know he like
he's supposed to be a like i need i need
him to be more of a badass is what i'm
saying and i'm not getting that
impression right now and i'm not liking
it i'm not liking it like in the
mandalorian
this guy is a badass the dude that plays
a man alone he's a badass and he's like
you know he's out here
killing and and he gets softened by this
little you know yoda creature that
gets comes into his life so you see the
transformation so you kind of feel for
him but at the same time you know he's a
badass we know nothing about this boba
fett
so it's only episode one but i didn't it
didn't grab me in episode one you know
what i'm saying like it didn't grab me
it didn't make me feel like
oh man this is gonna be good but you
know what sometimes it's a slow burn in
these star wars things because because
even mandalorian was like a slow burn i
just enjoyed the stylistic-ness of it
right
so with book of boba fett i just don't
know
i don't know yet so i don't know what
you guys feel about it right now so make
sure you like write in the comments of
your feelings about episode one and then
we'll just you know we'll go through the
season and figure out where wh what's
happening with this um with this show
but as of right now i'm i'm a little
lukewarm on it as of right now it only
gets about two woo-woos and then maybe
three moves because of potential
yeah so you know it gets three woo-woos
for the potential of where i believe
it's gonna go
so right now that's uh where we're at
with
the
book of boba fett you know
book of boba fett yeah
right now i'm giving it a yeah
all right
so but right now let's um
go back to
our great sponsor
um where is it doordash y'all
doordash man
uh i love doordash i use it all the time
um you know it's very easy and they have
all the good restaurants and stuff that
you know some of the other apps don't
have so i really enjoy doordash
uh you know
it's like
when you when you just want to get
something from like one of your favorite
local restaurants that's one of the
better restaurants doordash is
completely the way to go you know along
with the restaurants you love you can
now get groceries and other essential
items delivered with doordash get drinks
snacks other household items and you get
them all in under an hour sometimes
you're craving late night stuff like i
always talk about this great donut shop
that rachel and i like to get they have
like you know rice crispy donut rice
krispie treats donuts and you know they
have like these different flavors and
stuff and we get it from there and
they're only on doordash so it's that
kind of specific things that you can get
you know the ordering is easy and your
items will be left safely outside your
door if you want the contactless
delivery doordash is all about that
you know
you can get what you want to eat right
now
right to your door with door dash for a
limited time our listeners can get 25
off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the doordash app and enter code
griffin that's 25 off up to 10 value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code griffin
griff
don't forget that's code griffin for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
all right
um okay where are we at now i want to
okay i want to talk about this movie i
saw
on netflix
with rachel
um it was a it was it was a oh no that's
not it that's the book of boba fett
still let's go back boom it's called
it's called to the bone
to the bone and it starred lily collins
to the bone you know how on netflix they
have these like like names of the lists
and this one was under a list called
hidden gems
so that to me tells me that it's like
one of those movies that like
critically acclaimed people think it's
good but it didn't get a lot of hype and
and buzz about it
so but this was a i'm telling you it was
a really good movie well done movie it
stars lily collins that's who that is
right there
lily collins keanu reeves is in this he
plays like the psychiatrist that's kind
of like new age psychiatrist uh alex
sharp um
i don't know any i don't know most of
these people i know rita the girl rita i
didn't know she goes by one name now but
her name is rita and there's a lot of
really great actors and actresses
in this movie but it's called to the
bone and i am really i'm highly
recommending it this is a good one if
you're in a relationship grab your girl
or maybe
you know what this is actually a great
movie
um
i'll read you the synopsis ellen her the
lily collins stars is a girl named ellen
is an unruly 20 year old anorexic girl
who spent the better part of her teenage
years being
shepherded through various recovery
programs only to find herself severely
just several pounds under weight every
single time
it so it is a really great story that
depicts
eating disorders
seemingly in a very realistic way
how they're dealing with it
so
i just i feel like
it's it's a great movie to watch with
family you know maybe like teenage kids
to like really get a sense of you know
this is a real thing that goes on and i
i thought it was just a well-done movie
and well-acted so like lily collins i
don't know if it was cgi
i don't know if it was um
you know
they she was like super skinny in this
movie like
sickly skinny so i don't know if she did
that for the part or if she or if they
like you know did cgi on her but she's
already like a slender woman as it is so
i don't think it's probably that hard to
make her look like sickly skinny
a little asmr drinking for you sorry
but
it was good you know
and so like it's about it's about like
how these this these issues how it
affects families man
you know and they and
it's actually really well done you know
it's like
you know you you wonder
if you've ever met someone with some
sort of disorder like this and you start
to see that what's it really about and
it's just you know it's just about like
when you're a damaged soul man
like all the things that happen in your
life that contribute towards you feeling
the way you feel about yourself
having this self-doubt having this
feelings of like
you're not good enough and then you're
blaming it on the weight and but like
the you know
you know
these people all have some sort of issue
with their family or some traumatic
event and it's just
it's just such a there's a really sweet
moment to the movie this kid named alex
sharp he plays a kid named luke
and he's sort of the love interest of
this girl because she find like she's
been going from like
like
entry in treatment care
to different ones and they all don't
work now keanu reeves is playing this
sort of radical
doctor who has a way of like
communicating with these kids and he has
this like hard ass program
and you know he
he's just there's a sort of like a guide
you know for her and you know she goes
into this new program and she meets all
these people who are just like her and
they all have their thing you know
they're hiding their vomit and this one
they're working out like the way she
depicted it it was like really like i
felt for her you know it's like
these people with eating disorders they
also like they they they work out
heavily like she knew all the calories
of this stuff and she was all she was
just doing pushed sit-ups doing sit-ups
to the point where she was injuring her
back
you know
she she just the way she played this
character
lily lily collins uh
it really was a really good movie it's
an old movie apparently it came out in
2017.
i didn't realize that till right now as
i looked at this thing but you know when
you're on netflix and you're going
through and you're trying to see like
whatever movie
you know so this is my old school hidden
gem recommendation from netflix
it's called uh to the bone
uh starring uh lily collins keanu reeves
alex sharp and a bunch of people you
know it just showed up on the netflix
queue and uh i i i thoroughly enjoyed it
i thought it was a really well done i
don't know i don't have an eating
disorder well maybe i do you know when
you're fat you have an eating disorder
but you know
the way
it was being portrayed i thought it was
very powerful it was very heartfelt
and like you felt for this girl and you
hated her at the same time because i was
like you know it's you know it's like
when you see somebody with an issue like
this it's often so easy just to kind of
be like what the hell is wrong with you
like why are you acting like this like
you know like just just eat like you
know just
you know you know and it's like we just
don't get it i mean that's the hardest
thing to do is to like relate to
somebody that's dealing with something
that you just you have no
idea what they're dealing with or how
they're dealing with it so we kind of
just had this kind of like ah blase
attitude about it you know even just
like
i don't know if you guys saw
this past the past weekend that the
nfl football player antonio brown
this guy just
walked off the field man
he took off his pads
and he threw him
he took off his shirt he took off his
stuff and he threw his stuff into the
fan stands and he just bounced off the
field he just waved himself goodbye like
i'm out of here you know some stuff is
coming out today that like bruce the
head coach bruce aryan said to him hey
uh you know i need to go back in the
game he didn't want to go back in the
game
excuse me he didn't want to go back in
the game uh he's saying he was injured
even though it didn't look like he was
injured when he was you know dancing off
the field so i don't understand that
um
but
the reason why i'm bringing it up in
terms of this like to the bone is
you know
we look at antonio brown and we go dude
you're a first ballot hall of fame
wide receiver
you make millions of dollars and we're
like we don't understand why are you
acting crazy
like why are you sabotaging yourself all
the different things that happened he he
faked his vax card he you know he was
yelling at the cops in front of his kid
he got accused of sexual assault and
physical abuse of a couple of women uh
however how many it was uh you know he
he did the instagram lot he did the
facebook live video during in the locker
room when he was at pittsburgh you know
what i mean he got traded from
pittsburgh he was with buffalo but he
didn't play for buffalo he went to the
raiders he didn't like the raiders he
went to
the patriots tom brady fought for this
guy like tom brady vouched for him you
know and then he and then we thought he
was gonna make it you know he won a
super bowl last year and he contributed
they won
directly because of his contribution in
the super bowl
and you think oh you got it all together
man like what are you doing your life
seems to be like perfect and then
apparently it's not
you know
apparently it's not apparently there's
some issues and things going on with him
that us outsiders we look at it and we
go i don't know what the hell is up with
this guy
and i think that like getting back to
like with this movie i think that this
movie is a great depiction of like a
troubled person
that like it's not necessarily a likable
character but but you just kind of
empathize and you just kind of watch and
see like why how this person
self-destructs
um
so i highly recommend it check out to
the bone
and
you know
shout out to like real people dealing
with these real issues you know and
again it's like when you think about uh
you know
um i didn't i actually didn't plan on
talking about uh
antonio brown
but
you know it is what it is you know it's
a fluid thing we're doing this live
but yeah man i think that
oh see i see somebody in the chat i was
just gonna mention that thank you tech
there was this vicious hit
that
bert that guy
dante berfick i don't even know if that
guy's in the league anymore because he
was notorious
but this guy
he antonio brown he got hit by this guy
in the middle of the field and his whole
body crumpled like it was scary he was
like a rag doll you can look that up you
can youtube that that hit just look up
that hit
of antonio brown and he pretty much
hasn't been the same i mean you already
know about like anton what is his name
aaron hernandez they examined his brain
and he looks like he had cte and it you
know did the cte make him a murderer or
did it like mess with his impulse
control but
it seems as if something is really wrong
with antonio brown
okay
seems like something is really wrong
with it and it's like you know uh again
though it's like it's hard to feel sorry
for someone
looking from the outside when we look at
this and go well look at all these
things that he's done
is all of this like how can you it's
like how can you have the discipline
the discipline to be
a nfl wide receiver at such a high level
like that guy's a first ballot hall of
fame wide receiver probably
top five greatest wide receiver of all
time if he hadn't messed up his career
who knows where his numbers would be and
where we would rank him all time but
he's up there with randy moss jerry rice
calvin johnson these type of guys
his career numbers
it's just it's incredible when you look
at his numbers so anyway my point is he
had the ability
to like practice
and play at a high level
in the nfl you would think that that
sort of discipline would carry over
into another person's life
into like your regular life
but apparently it doesn't work like that
because there are other examples
of people who seem to be even good
citizens
but the cte you know
affected them
um
and yeah like that somebody else meant
thank you for mentioning like junior
seoul from the san diego chargers he
killed himself
turns out you know they examined him and
the cte was a part of his so we don't
know how this thing is affecting these
people and it's like it's you know it's
hard to have empathy when you look from
the outside in because you're just kind
of like yo you got everything you got
millions of dollars you play a
you play a child's game for a living
like can't you just keep your [ __ ]
together
but he just he just apparently couldn't
do it and what a bizarre scene right
like even in our minds we're looking at
this and we're like man
like you're making millions of dollars
you're on your last leg you already just
got suspended from doing something
stupid and this is it for you and he
just made a choice like it looked like
he was just like you know what i'm out
like i'm done with this i'm done playing
by anybody else's rules
but
and like i hope i don't even know if he
has family man
if he has anyone looking out for his
best interest
because you got to think this dude gonna
be broke like
does he have his money saved is it being
invested
like i just don't know man
like i wouldn't even be surprised if
like you know
he's just in five years on the streets
because he just has like
nothing left
oh
i don't know man
you know and it you know
yeah and i and i i i agree with you like
there is an idea that some people in the
chat are saying like what if he's just
an idiot you know what if he's just what
if this is who he is
i just i don't i i don't know it's hard
for me
like it's not easy to get into the nfl
even if you're a talented athlete
there's a certain skill level you have
to achieve to be play at that high a
level
so you would think there's got to be
something in his head that
he can just last week man just last week
he had a great game for the uh bucks
i just feel like he just snapped man he
just was like i'm done i'm out i don't
want to do this anymore
and here he is
he's just like
whatever you know
so our heart goes out to antonio brown
hope he gets his hope he gets it
together
all right last thing i want to talk
about this week is as you know
i play
a lot
of um
wait here we go
i'm on eric griffin gaming
daily
so make sure you check me out
you know check me out on twitch
eric griffin gaming
eric griffith
gaming on twitch
the primary game i play a lot of is call
of duty
i play call of duty almost every day i
love this game
it's a battle royale called warzone
they had their map before for dan's map
that's like a fake sort of like eastern
european city and now they have this
like pacific you know call of duty in
this war zone map it's like it's very
like
very hawaii 1920s it's like world war ii
uh motif
and
so if you don't know what a battle
royale game is you basically have this
map and there's like a circle on the map
and the circle closes every there's like
a timer on the circle and it keeps
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
and smaller and you have to fight to the
center of the circle and the last person
standing or the last team standing wins
and it's really exciting and thrilling
it's it's such a challenging game and
it's always different that's why battle
royales are so fun you got pub g you got
apex you got fortnite
and call of duty and there's some other
ones too that they they have out there
but those are the big ones
and you know they're just super
challenging games that's why they're so
addictive so my thoughts on the new map
and uh
warzone so the new map looks great
i missed the old map i missed for dance
because i you know i think i spent more
time during quarantine in for dance than
i did in real life i just really i knew
that mad backwards and forwards i know
every nook and cranny of it because i
was playing the game for a year almost
every day and then when we were
quarantined i'm playing five six hours a
day because i became a professional game
streamer so i consider myself a
professional game streamer i get paid to
game i get paid and the pay was it pays
good i've gotten some i have some great
opportunities i've gotten this so i'm a
pro streamer y'all i'm just not a pro
gamer and a sense of like i'm not like
the best at the game but i i hold my own
i'm having pretty good
pretty good time with the uh with the
game so
you know
i knew that map so we would be screaming
for a new map for so long so we finally
got this new map
we got the new map now the map's
beautiful what i love about the map is
it's like there's not a lot of repeat of
buildings and designs that's one thing
that verdance the last map the last war
zone map that was an issue like there
was only maybe seven buildings and they
were these same seven buildings were all
over the map
in little clusters
and so it was all the same design even
though the map looked like it was like
you know
a different map but you know you would
get into a building and be like oh i
know the design of this building because
this building is just like eight other
buildings that's that i've been in in
one in the map so this one they really
went out of their way to have like a
very
unique
every part of the map is pretty unique
there's not a lot of repeat of design
and structure it's very rich map there's
trees and hills and you know
there's a lot of great stuff on the map
now if they just came out with the map
and like you know tweaked that i think
we'd be fine
but my problem is
it's world war ii guns the game is
called
modern
warfare
call of duty modern warfare and now
we're in this
1920s 30s whatever world war ii
with these terrible guns
they're trash
the reason why you haven't even heard of
these guns before is because they were
retired in world war ii
so the fact that they are still they're
using them in this
game is infuriating
you know it's just a few and then
so what they did was they came out with
a ver a multiplayer version and a
campaign version of the game called
vanguard
all right so this is how they get you
war zones free so you can play warzone
for free anybody can download it and
it's cross platforms pretty dope but
let's say
you know all the guns have different
attachments and different levels the
more you play with the gun the more you
level it up the more you can like make
it look good too with with camos and
like charms and stickers that's the
whole
sort of like casino
vibe of these games these days they're
making it so you have to like you know
some people spend real their own spend
real money to buy blueprints of these
guns in the game
so so what they tend to do is they'll
come out with like a
a version of guns these vanguard guns
and to rank them up you have to play
warzone but it's hard to rank up a gun
just playing war zone they want you to
spend the 60 on vanguard and play the
multiplayer where you can rank up the
guns and that rank up carries over to
the war zone so
i enjoy playing vanguard
you know what i mean it's fun because
i'm ranking up to guns but the guns i
don't like them i just don't like the
guns
and so
then they have this mode where
so now you have you know the modern
warfare guns you have the cold war guns
that was another
multiplayer that came out a couple years
a year ago or however when it was and
now you have vanguard so there's
different guns different sets of guns
in each of these multiplayer games and
you can use them all in modern warfare
but this season they have this thing
called vanguard royale where you can
only use the vanguard guns i hate it
i hate it
because i want to use all i want to be
able to use all the guns and this and
this is another thing that they do that
i can't stand thumbs down on this is
they'll nerf the guns so there'll be a
gun that you can use and you like it
it's pretty good you you feel like
you're pretty good with it and then the
the the makers will go all right that
gun's too overpowered or
now we're gonna mess with it and make it
where
it's unusable we're gonna make the
recoil bad or we're gonna do and they do
this all the time and what they've done
is they've made all the modern warfare
guns terrible
now they're doing the same thing to the
cold war guns so now they're trying to
force us to play with these vanguard
guns and they're forcing us to and i
don't like it man i don't like it
they nerfed the guns into the ground
you know it's terrible
all right now they have a bunch of
issues the game is full of bugs
all right it's full of dev errors like i
play on console i play on an xbox and
the game keeps
crashing like if i'm playing with my
buddies
the game will be playing and then all of
a sudden
it'll crash
and that just keeps happening
so that's annoying then there's these
little bugs in the game that keep
happening
and so you would think hey why don't you
release the game
let's get as the bugs happen we fix them
no they decided to add
this
stupid
christmas stuff
all right so there's this character
called krampus
all right and so krampus is like the you
know
sort of like a evil christmas
character oh by the way i just saw
someone in chat said battlefield 2042 is
dope
you're crazy that game is garbage
anyways
um let's go back to this so they had
this character called krampus
and it's like this evil christmas
character that just appears out of
nowhere and will keep chasing you and
throwing like snowballs that take off
your armor in the middle of a battle
royale so like you're playing solo
you're in a solo match there's like 20
people left and all of a sudden krampus
starts chasing you and you have to shoot
him so everybody in the map know oh you
know oh that guy's being chased by
krampus and they come get you so you get
third partied it's so annoying it is the
most unfun thing i've ever experienced
in a video game of this magnitude it's
like i don't know one person that plays
this game that is like oh man that
christmas stuff is real fun
it's like the makers of the game are
trolling us
you know
they have such an abusive relationship
with us
it's so crazy
like yeah you can look at my instagram
where i have a live i put a video up
from my from my
twitch
which is eric griffin gaming i am on
there live every day um
you know if you see this krampus just
shows up out of nowhere and starts
chasing you so that's annoying and then
they have these like elves
these elves that like you have to shoot
an elf
and then
like two more up here you have to find
them then you get a bunch of loot but
the sound sets the the soundscape of the
game is a little wonky so you can't tell
if something is up or down or sideways
and so that's annoying and i just want
this christmas nonsense to be over with
apparently they have like a big huge bug
fixes coming to the game
apparently that's like something that's
happening this week
i hope it happens soon because
i really love this game and i play the
game all the time but this is the first
time that i've been like one of these
people that's like oh man this game is
it's it's gonna it's turning into trash
and i hate feeling like that but that's
what they're doing
and thankfully for them
battlefield 2042
is a is just a a huge
failure
that game is a huge
failure all right oh if you want to know
what kind of gaming chair i use i use e
win
racing chair e win racing i actually
have a code on my twitch if you go to my
twitch you can get 30 percent off and
get a chair i love this share it's very
good and they're sending me actually
sending me a new one so when i put that
one together i'll be using that on my
podcast and stuff like that too but
thank goodness for
uh warzone they're lucky that
battlefield is garbage
oh man i should have put a picture up of
battlefield and talk about that but that
i'm not going to go into that too much
that game is just soulless
there's just no there's the game's
pointless the reason why battle royales
are so good is because not only are you
fighting people
picking up guns ranking up guns and
doing the little like missions in game
the circle is closing at the same time
so you have this like thrill this
exhilaration you feel that i won the
game like there's nothing better than a
warzone victory man when you finish and
your team is the last one standing or
you're doing a solo and you're the last
one standing you're like yes it feels
like it's a crazy feeling
battlefield there's nothing like that
you're just in a game doing nothing
there's no point to it like like the
people that made the game are so
stubborn they think that they can make
something better than a battle royale
just make a battle royale
warzone
apex
pubg
uh uh what's uh um the stupid one
fortnite
these are all battle royales
all right and they have their own take
on it but it is the best form of that
type of game and so for battlefield to
think that they can do oh we're gonna do
it
better it's like man [ __ ] off man you
guys suck
you know and i heard a story that like
the creators some of the gaming creators
at
um
the battlefield ea
they were trying to tell them hey let's
do something different and then they
they didn't do it and so a lot of those
people
left the company i think to start their
own company so
you know it is what it is
but um
i still am in very much enjoying war
zone if you want to watch me play like i
say i do play
daily
i play daily
uh you know i love that game so much
i've never really been like a gamer and
now i feel like like i'm a huge gamer
now so make sure you guys check me out
on
like i said twitch erica from gaming hit
me with a follow you know got a lot of
great subscribers too
but hey guys um
[Music]
you know we did it
uh
listen i'm gonna be
every week i'm still doing riffle with
griffin make sure you check out the new
episode of gender gen that podcast is
still going we just we had to take a
break because of different factors
coving and all this kind of stuff so
uh
that a new episode of that is coming out
so make sure you check that out and also
catch me every week on king of the sting
shout out to those guys
king and the sting guys theo brendan
lee uh steve lee
and all the crew nick and chen and the
crew over there so check me out on uh
king of the sting um and then i got my
calendar i got some dates coming up i'm
gonna be in michigan i'm gonna be in
canada twice i'll be in calgary and i'm
also gonna be in edmonton so make sure
you guys check that out let's hope those
flights don't get canceled and i can get
in and out of that damn country without
an issue
so um yeah
you know
we did it man um i'm gonna be doing real
world advice from a grown ass man i'll
be doing that and i'll be doing a lot of
movie reviews a lot of show reviews i'm
a cuban about that because i really
enjoy doing that so i'm gonna make this
about that so
happy new year everybody i appreciate
the love and support that i get from you
guys and again put your comments don't
be rude and i might read your comment on
next week's episode to the continue the
discussion about stuff
uh you know the boba fett show
uh make sure you check out to the bone
it's a great movie on netflix watch it
with your girl or your guy
uh your family it's one of those movies
a really really touching really
heartfelt really powerful movie
starring lily collins and if you're
playing warzone stick with it i think
they're going to make some changes and
fix the game so let's hope so but you
know i'll see you guys
next week appreciate y'all
[Music]